this one has its own sort of sneaky
thing on it so I'll help you out and
then I want to see how I can get on your
own okay without me holding it all right
let's like we did before sorry I didn't
give you a space at the top let's write
this again down the bottom so that we
can actually do some like work on this
thing it says y equals to f of X where
is it plus one right cool
all right now just like in the previous
question you have to do some
rearrangements before you start putting
Pendergraft okay so the first thing I
wanna point out is see how that X is
inside the brackets right and I sent you
that picture of the scram like things
have to be close to the X to change the
X the two numbers here the two the +1
they're not related to the X at all so
even though the first graph we did all
of the changes are horizontal changes
here and not gonna be horizontal okay so
it's a big clue so well okay let's let's
do that as a suggestion so if I divide
by two well let's let's try it out okay
so if I divide by 2 I get Y divided by 2
equals what I get on the right hand side
very good ok now I can immediately say
see that Y over 2 that's this dilation
idea that that over 2 is directly acting
on Y so this dilation but it's not gonna
be an X dilation it's gonna be a wide
dilation okay so this is gonna be some
vertical bigger or smaller um is it
bigger or smaller very good so this is
actually we didn't graph this but it was
the example that I said over here
yeah when you everything's read a
backwards you divide things get bigger
you multiply like the example we just
did things get squashed in okay so good
that's fantastic right so that half
because it's not inside with the X even
though it's over on the right hand side
it's not changing X at all so if we
subtract anything I get Y over 2 take
away a half equals f of X
well well I'm gonna ask you the question
I'm gonna ask you the question right um
it's not that I don't like it I just
think we're not done this suggests a
dilation what's the other kind of change
that we get from this transformations
the general word we used to apply to all
of these so the particular kind of
transformation is it's not with trans as
well but it's translation oh so it's the
slide or the shift right but how far is
the slide or the shift now looks like
it's a half but there's two big problems
okay number one is it horizontal or is
it vertical have a think when we had a
look at our previous example right aha
so so in this first example it was
impacting on X so it's horizontal but
this guy is impacting on Y you can see
it over there on the left hand side
right so therefore it's gonna be an
up-and-down thing okay but even more you
remember how we saw like ah that minus
six from before was not minus six okay
this isn't minus 1/2 either there's a
factorization we can do here now we
could multiply by two but that will undo
like you see yeah you told me to divide
by 2 here right so what I'm gonna do is
remember when we had that 2x minus 6 we
factorized so what's the common factor
on the left hand side to be a weird
because they're fraction yeah isn't the
common factor 1/2 yeah like you've got y
and x 1/2 and then you've got 1/2 right
so if I factorize that what do I get
left with one of great things about
factorizing whenever you're in doubt is
like today did I factorize it right you
just expand it yeah just just undo it
and you are 1/2 x y gives me Y on to 1/2
times minus 1 excuse me - off so I'm
good to go
equals f of X ok fantastic so the sneaky
thing about this to begin with is all
these numbers look like they are on the
right hand side changing things over
there but yeah you can see they're not
actually in with the X right so they
really all belong on the left
okay all right so now we've got to
changing we kind of already said this
along the way but let's just make sure
we've got it stated one at a time okay
you told me that that half is going to
be a um it's going to make things bigger
vertically so it's going to stretch
vertically how far and it's gonna be
double right yeah so I'm gonna say this
is twice as tall
oops I can spell twice as tall okay and
then what does that minus one do which
way am I gonna go hmm hold on
it's very cool it's very good okay so
number one it's vertical so it's either
gonna be up or down right it's gonna be
up or down right and it's gonna be up
cuz everything's backwards y ou isn't -1
which is going up okay so it's twice as
tall and then it's gonna be one unit
upward okay so now at the same point
that we were before we know what the
transformations are order of operations
do you dilation first and then do your
your shift okay all right um we did this
before and you kind of already know what
those points are that we're on nice
spots I want you to find them again and
then see if you can work out what their
Y values should be yeah let's just find
this bots yeah good idea
so I think we had we have all these
spots okay now just before you go any
further right you've mocked them all in
yet okay now remember last time in fact
let's just look at that page before
right what I did was I said oh the x
value remember had two intercepts you
had an x intercept of 4 over there and I
said it's x value is 4 yeah so we we
have that thing right but now for this
problem we're not thinking about X
values at all with you about values
right so if I have a look we're making
everything twice as tall right let's go
from left to right so this guy over here
it's x value is negative 1 but I don't
care I'm not interested in X values yeah
right I'm looking it's Y value what is
this Y value negative 5 so what am I
going to do to that I want this thing to
be yeah I want it to be twice as tall so
negative five becomes it is oh yes I'm
doubling it right okay so we were doing
redexes for this stage the first
transmission so it's down the bottom
there at negative two yeah exactly it's
still the same x-value because we didn't
change it yeah we changed the y-value
good the next ones at the origin so
what's its y-value yeah it's y-value is
zero your double zero you get zero okay
so we'll put an X 10 good next very good
so Y value of 3 turns into 6 next one
along the 4 turns into an age yeah
exactly because that symmetry right I
know look at this one right previously
we looked at the x value and therefore
it changed what's the Y value of this
intercept it's still 0 which is really
helpful because what that means is in
fact can you imagine if I had another
graph which had more intercepts what
intercepts if I had like a bunch of X
intercepts over like here and over here
right all of them have a y-value of 0 so
they'd all just go to the same spot so
um you know if I'm doing a vertical
dilation all the X intercepts end up
identical you've done them all now we've
got one last point of the right-hand
side where's it go yep perfect
ok so I'm just like before I'm just
gonna do like a little dotted line to
connect out yep that's ok so you can see
it's like the parabola we started with
but it's kind of steeper yeah mm-hmm or
taller I think was the word I used
before so that's good
I've done dilation and now what's the
other change I need to make yeah so that
minus one one unit upward so those same
five points I'm just going to push them
up yeah very good so we'll go over to
our other color it's really easy because
1 units so easy to see yeah it's like ah
ok I can do this in a fairly um quick
way I don't even think about the numbers
really yeah because you're just looking
at the grid lines right yeah exactly I
so do you reckon you could try and fit
in all together yeah exactly it's tricky
to be precise isn't it you can see why I
totally recommend people use pencil like
when you're actually doing it because
like I've been doing this for years and
it's still really hard to get precise
the first time so there's no shame in
trying to get it somewhere and then
fixing it up if that's not that's very
that's a very common like I've already
I've already like undone and read on my
graph several times so yeah we go okay
all right um having a look at yours how
do you feel with that okay it's cute I
would definitely say like you said like
that that the vertex it's
super-important it's a stationary point
and like we know enough calculus now to
know like it has to be smooth at that
point so if I looked at your graph and
I'm like oh it's a bit pointy I've
definitely get my pencil I'd be rubbing
that out fixing that up so you get the
right shape because the shape is kind of
important to the graph okay